[Musique]
femme vie liberté ce slogan résonne tous
les week-ends
place de la République de nombreux
manifestants sont venus apporter leur
soutien au mouvement né depuis la mort
de Marsa Amini jeune curdiranienne
décédée deux mois plus tôt
[Applaudissements]
parmi eux sa naze une danseuse de 31 ans
arrivée en France il y a trois ans elle
a encore sa famille et ses amis en Iran
et compte bien être leur voix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la danse est c'est ma façon de
m'exprimer c'est ma façon de se tenir
mon couple
dans son pays d'origine sa naze n'aurait
jamais pu sortir sans son voile ni
s'exprimer avec son corps en public
c'est comme ça qu'on devait sortir c'est
ça qui rappelle les gens sont en train
pour se battre pour dire que bah on peut
choisir de où mettre ça on peut choisir
de le mettre ici à côté de nos hanches
pas sur la tête forcément et danser avec
les images de la répression en Iran
circulent massivement au sein de la
diaspora Kevin médecin de 27 ans est né
en France de parents iraniens ce soir il
est allé dîner dans un restaurant du
quartier persan avec sa petite amie
française
d'habitude il ne suit pas tellement les
informations mais en ce moment c'est
différent depuis 40 jours surtout au
début toutes les 15 minutes j'allais sur
mon téléphone et essayer de voir s'il y
avait du nouveau il a aussi décidé
d'agir à son échelle je suis
majoritairement les la révolution parce
que c'est une révolution iranienne sur
Instagram
c'est un endroit où le média les sources
de médias ne sont pas forcément filtrées
j'essaye de partager les informations
que j'ai de dévoiler un peu ce qui se
passe même dans mon dans mes amis
proches il y en a qui parfois ne savent
pas ce qui se passe en Iran je trouve
qu'il y a peu faire ça pour elle encore
plus loin au-delà des manifestations qui
sont mises en place mais par des gens
qui ont été iranienne malheureusement
parce que je pense qu'il pourrait avoir
aussi une action beaucoup plus concrète
quand on a pu le voir par exemple en
[Musique]
ukrainement
cette voyage quand on fait à la mère de
l'Iran la caspien on était jeune
vraiment étudiant aucun
problème pour les sorties les filles et
avec les garçons
des vacances entre amis des robes des
pantalons pas d'éléphant c'est la
jeunesse Dassin en Iran dans les années
c'est mon ancien passeport iranien à
l'époque que je quitte mon pays avec ce
passeport mais je suis entré ici
le 17 août 80 1980 partisan du chat il
est parti juste après sa mort il n'est
jamais revenu mais même en France l'Iran
ne l'a jamais quitté
il reçoit tous les jours des images de
la répression via WhatsApp et là tu es
regardé c'est un temps
son père comme moi il est resté il est
en train de laver pour leur faire
enterrement là vous voyez c'est dire
qu'ils ont été comment ils ont tué là en
quatre décennies il a vu de nombreuses
révoltes se lever contre le régime au
pouvoir pour lui celle-ci est différente
100% optimiste parce que vous voyez jour
et nuit les gens iraniens les jeunes
Iraniens ils ont dans la haut les jours
et nuit c'est en tout cas son souhait
tant que ce gouvernement est là il ne
peut pas retourner en Iran
qu'est-ce que ça m'a
c'est mon pays qui m'a manqué
j'aimerais bien montrer mes enfants
aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
partagent le même rêve un changement
Niro pour pouvoir y retourner librement
aujourd'hui environ 40000 iraniens
vivent en France pour beaucoup d'entre
eux l'accès au pays est impossible ou
trop risqué sous ce régime
[Musique]